One of the most lucrative endorsements ever
signed by any sportsman was not for some shoe,
line of clothing, or athletic gear- but for
a cooking item- The George Foreman Lean Mean
Fat-Reducing Grilling Machine.
In fact, the deal is generally thought to
have made the former boxing great drastically
more money than he ever made fighting in the
ring.
(And, if you’re curious, see: Why Boxing
Rings are Called Rings When They are Square)
According to the grill’s inventor, Michael
Boehm, the inspiration for the grill’s unique
design came when he was walking around a department
store in the late 1980s and he noticed that
not a single grill for sale cooked meat on
both sides.
Boehm, a lifelong inventor and tinkerer, rushed
home and sketched an idea for a grill that
did exactly that, as well as drained fat away
while the item cooked.
To test the concept, Boehm bought some cast
iron skillets, placed them at an angle and
then tried cooking burgers on the contraption,
measuring how much of the fat was drained
away.
The crude device worked and Boehm refined
the idea, adding such features as a floating
hinge (so that it could evenly cook things
of varying size) and a separate reservoir
that the fat would drain into, making cleaning
the grill that much easier.
Boehm later claimed that he knew from day
one that the grill was going to be a huge
success, noting that “It was different;
it had some magic and it fulfilled a need.”
At the time, Boehm was the general manager
of a Chinese manufacturer of electronics called
Tsann Kuen USA.
While Tsann Kuen USA did eventually end up
selling a version of the grill dubbed the
“Short Order Grill”, it sold poorly, prompting
Boehm to begin pitching the grill to other
manufacturers, all of whom showed him the
door.
As Boehm later elaborated:
They initially seemed indifferent, even skeptical.
That was true of just about everyone I showed
it to, [they told me] you can’t cook on
an angle!
It’s like anything new, something people
haven’t seen before.
If it’s so great, people say, it would have
already been invented.
Well… that’s not necessarily the case.
Ignoring the naysayers, Boehm continued to
pitch his idea, eventually catching the eye
of Salton Inc. (now known as Spectrum Brands)
in 1994, who agreed to manufacture the device.
Now all Boehm needed was a spokesman, which
is where Hulk Hogan allegedly came swaggering
in.
The Hulkster has changed his story on this
one over time, initially claiming during an
episode of Hogan Knows Best that his agent
called him to tell him of the offer to have
Hogan endorse the grill, but Hogan missed
the call.
This purportedly resulted in the agent switching
gears and working out a deal for the grill
for one of his other clients- George Foreman.
This, of course, makes no sense at all as
no agent who wanted to keep his job would
do such a thing simply over a missed phone
call.
In an interview in 2011, Hogan changed the
story to something a bit more plausible- he
was approached by his agent in the 1990s about
the idea of endorsing a line of kitchen products.
Mr. America was then pitched three different
devices his agent had managed to wrangle him
offers for: a meatball maker, a blender and
a grill.
While Hogan liked the idea of putting his
name on a meatball maker and a blender, with
the latter being released under the awesome
moniker of The Hulk Hogan Thunder Mixer, he
passed on the grill, allegedly telling his
agent “Ah, give that to your other client.”
That client?
George Foreman.
As interesting an anecdote as this is, and
as much as it’s often claimed to be “fact”
by various otherwise reputable outlets, Boehm
has never confirmed either of The Hulkster’s
versions of events, maintaining that he always
intended to have George Foreman be his spokesman
after seeing him passionately endorse some
mufflers in a TV ad.
As a result, it’s not really clear whether
or not Hogan was ever actually a potential
candidate to endorse the grill as he has claimed.
It may even be the case that Hogan was simply
offered an endorsement of a grill that was
not the product that became the George Foreman
Grill, but later confused it as such.
(Hogan did later endorse a product known as
the Hulk Hogan Ultimate Grill.)
Whatever the case, according to Boehm, Salton
Inc sent a prototype grill and some information
about it to Foreman after getting in contact
with his lawyer.
Unfortunately for them, they were promptly
stonewalled by the former champ for several
months.
Foreman’s lawyer, Sam Perlmutter, would
later recall that Foreman’s immediate reaction
to the grill was less than enthusiastic, with
the boxer taking one look at it and flatly
stating, “I’m not interested in toys”.
This was a bit odd as Foreman was known to
be a huge lover of hamburgers and had once
noted he made a practice of carefully draining
the fat from every piece of meat he cooked-
the very thing the grill was literally invented
to do.
Despite this being the perfect product for
Foreman, the prototype grill sat in his kitchen
for a reported six months until his wife decided
to use it to make his children a grilled cheese
sandwich.
The result?
Mary would later state in an interview, “I
told him I tried that grill.
I really love that grill and it was easy for
me because having a bunch of kids, you just
put the stuff on there — and especially
children love grilled cheese sandwiches.”
Nevertheless, Foreman remained unconvinced
about the grill until his wife made him a
hamburger with it.
He stated of this momentous burger, “The
grease, everything went away and the meat
was delicious.
So I called my partners back and said, ‘I’m
going to do that deal’.”
Perhaps thanks to being a long-time holdout
on this one, Foreman was given pretty ridiculously
favourable terms in the deal; in exchange
for promoting the grill and slapping his name
on it, Foreman was promised a whopping 40%
of the profits of each grill sold.
This was 25% more than Boehm, the guy who
invented the thing, received.
The remaining 45% of the profits went to Salton
Inc.
Launched in 1994 as “The George Foreman
Lean Mean Fat-Reducing Grilling Machine”
the grill would eventually become a huge success,
to date having sold well over 100 million
units.
Sales of the grill netted Foreman so much
money in royalties that they actually influenced
his decision to finally hang up his boxing
gloves at the age of 48.
According to Foreman, after his 1997 loss
against Shannon Briggs (Foreman’s last ever
professional bout), he sat in his locker room
feeling sorry for himself when his lawyer
walked in and handed him a comically large
cheque large not only in dimensions, but amount,
despite being royalties for only a single
month of sales.
To quote Foreman:
That was one of the happiest days of my business
life.
I lost my last professional boxing match,
[but] I’d received a check for $1 million
for the grill.
While Foreman has never officially stated
how much money he’s received from sales
of the grill in total, conservative estimates
taking into account his royalties, which at
the peak of the grill’s success were totaling
about $4.5 million per month, and the $137
million he was paid in 1998 by Salton Inc
to buy him out of future royalties, it’s
generally estimate that Foreman made well
over $200 million (adjusted for inflation,
about $300 million today) from the grill;
this is approximately 2.5 times what he earned
during his prestigious career
in
the ring.